cela fait une dizaine d'années
qu'olivier son épouse recueille des
animaux abandonnés
d'abord en région parisienne puis ici en
loir et cher leur dernière acquisition
c'est en juillet dernier marguerite une
miraculée c'est une vache échappée d'un
abattoir dans le rhône et
résumé à grands frais par une
association qui nous l'a déposé ici
début juillet sur une quinzaine
d'hectares plus de 300 animaux
cohabitent des espèces aussi diverses
que des chouettes des uns des lamas des
wallabys et des loups tous abandonnés ou
maltraités par des maîtres sans scrupule
un budget 50000 euros par an ce qui est
très peu pour
autant d'animaux mais le vétérinaire qui
mon épouse intervient gratuitement sur
l'ensemble du refuge
ce sont des économies énormes tout le
monde est bénévole
on fait tout nous-mêmes en fait notre
foi l'association fonctionne en effet
sans aucune aide
grâce à quelques dons et surtout une
trentaine de bénévoles qui participent
aux activités du refuge j'entretiens
tout ce qui est des tracteurs mais
ministre - n'étant deux toutous voitures
scooters de tours en fin de compte ici
les soins sont assurés par stéphane il
épouse qui est vétérinaire une vingtaine
d'animaux sont actuellement soignés
entre la cuisine la salle à manger et la
bibliothèque un petit chevreau qui est
pas dans la cuisine qui est donc de
l'autre côté la cuisine c'est vraiment
la faune sauvage là du coup passé de la
faune domestique mais l'aîné il est né
prématurément et est de ce fait la maman
n'avait pas de lait et donc on est
obligé de biberonner prochains objectifs
de l'association devenir ferme
pédagogique et accueillir des personnes
handicapées et en réinsertion